[Applaudissements]
quand les organisateurs de cette édition
a appelé pour m'inviter ils m'ont dit
que le thème c'était les connexions donc
j'ai raccroché
je me suis dit mais oui je suis allé
dans des hôtels où il y avait pas de
wifi je suis dans des zones où mon
téléphone capte mal voire pas du tout
mais je vais pas avoir grand chose à
dire je vais pas tenir tout un speech
devant vous et puis finalement j'ai
appris que c'était les connexions
interpersonnelles humaine plus générale
est donc là je me suis dit bah en fait
oui c'est exactement ça mon métier
journaliste s'est connecté l'audience le
grand public via son média avec les gens
qu'on rencontre avec nos sources et avec
les infos il ya un journaliste qui
allait céder que j'aimais beaucoup qui
s'appelle rémy kolpa kopoul et qui lui
se décrivait comme un collectionneur
bonjour je m'appelle benoît chaumont je
suis journaliste
j'ai 40 ans ça fait 18 ans que je fais
ce métier et ces dernières années j'ai
fait une série de reportages qui
s'appelle le dictature tour donc comme
son nom l indique c l'idée c'était de
faire le tour des pays les plus fermés
au monde les plus déconnectés en touche
en effet une douzaine évidemment en
termes de dictature la meilleure ou la
pire évidemment c'est toujours la corée
du nord
le problème quand on veut faire un
reportage en corée du nord c'est que il
faut il y aller
et pour ça il ya quelques journalistes
ces dernières années qu'on réussit à y
aller en montrant patte blanche qui sont
soigneusement triés sur le volet par le
régime qui vont couvrir des cérémonies
où des défilés militaires mais moi ça
n'aurait pas pu marcher parce que ça
faisait déjà un moment que je faisais
les dictatures tour et donc quand on
tapait mon nom sur google on tombait
directement sur le mâchonnement
dictature tour je pense qu'il n'aurait
pas aimé il n'aurait pas invité il ya
une note un autre moyen d'y aller donc
c'est en touriste parce que c'est
possible et quelques agences de voyages
notamment chinoise qui propose de faire
des tours en corée du nord donc je me
suis dit que j'allais faire ça que
j'allais y aller en touriste mais quand
vous inscrivez sur le site de l' agence
de voyages la première question qui vous
pose c'est est-ce que vous êtes
journaliste ou photoreporter donc donc
là j'ai dû
j'ai dû mentir et je leur ai dit que
j'étais cuisinier à domicile et je me
suis même créé un faux site de cuisiner
à domicile enfin c'est pas moi ont aidé
à le faire je sais pas faire ça mais
avec ma photo déguisés en cuisiniers et
on a payé pour référencer le site pour
qu'il arrive en tête quand vous là pour
le coup de taper mon nom sur google vous
tombiez sur benoît chaumont cuisinier à
domicile donc comme ça j'étais plus
crédible pour pouvoir m'inscrire et
qu'un avocat ou sur place si jamais ils
avaient des doutes lors je leur ai
montré le site de cuisinier à domicile
mais ça a tellement bien marché que j'ai
même eu des demandes de devis sur le
site et donc mauges et puis allez aimer
l'histoire que qui à mon avis montre le
plus l'impossibilité de se connecter aux
nord-coréens
j'ai pas pu la filmer parce qu'on a
beaucoup filmé nos vacances notre
tournage mais on en n'a pas pu tout
filmé quoi et on en était accompagné par
par des par des guides font plutôt
surveillés par des guides pente où
toutes nos vacances et un soir enfin ces
deux guides donc elles sont comme 99%
des nord coréens ne sont jamais sortis
du pays mais elles ont eu le pré vie le
privilège d'apprendre l'anglais est en
fait quand on y pense c'est elles font
partie des rares nord-coréen qui qui
sont en contact avec le monde extérieur
puisqu'elle voit toute la journée des
touristes étrangers et un soir on buvait
un verre avec elle et il y en a une qui
curieusement
nous posent des questions sur sur obama
elle voulait en savoir plus et là
l'autre qui était à côté la fusille du
regard et lui demande d'arrêter de
stopper d'arrêter de poser des questions
quoi et en fait j'ai compris que c'était
interdit de poser pour elle de poser des
questions sur ce qui se passait à
l'extérieur et là j'ai compris surtout
la puissance de la dictature
il ya une autre série de reportages que
j'ai réalisé pour canal+ qui s'appelle
fuck le système donc toujours avec des
gens déconnecté puisque fac le système
c'était des immersions dans des
communautés qui vivent en marge de la
société qui vivent en dehors du monde
moderne
et là le le reportage qui m'a le plus
marqué c'était chez les ch et les
mennonites les mennonites ce sont les
couches les cousins germains des amish
mais en version beaucoup plus hardcore
donc ça donne la petite maison à prairie
mixé avec délivrance pour ceux qui ont
vu le film me comprendre et donc les
mennonites ils vivent en vase clos et
pour des raisons religieuses
il refuse le progrès la modernité et et
donc ils vivent entre les mennonites
parle une langue qui n'existe plus qui
s'appelle le bal mans mais même leur bas
allemand en fait il existe encore moins
puisque quand je suis rentré j'ai voulu
faire traduire les échanges des mélodies
que j'avais rencontré qui parlaient
entre eux donc pour savoir ce qui se
disait
et j'ai appelé l'institut goethe j'ai
trouvé un traducteur de baham enquêtait
pas débordé et et qui est qui et qui je
lui ai envoyé mes enfants mes
enregistrements il a écouté et en fait
ils comprenaient pas toi ils sont
tellement rester entre eux en bolivie
donc je vous soumets donc c'est des
mennonites qui sautent habitants
bolivien et ils sont tellement rester
entre eux que leur langue a buté et
cette traductrice neveu ne comprenait
pas quoi chez les mennonites donc on n'a
pas roulé en calèche et
parce qu'on appellera la modernité et
saufs il ya une entorse c'est le
tracteur ils ont des tracteurs pour
travailler dans les champs mais leurs
tracteurs à eux il n'a pas de dison
vivante à des pneus les tracteurs mais
des mets des roues avec des lames en
acier pour éviter aux tracteurs de
sortir de la colonie pour pas que les
jeunes en fait s'échapper puis le
tracteur ne peut aller que sur des
petites routes et pas sur les chemins à
l'extérieur donc voilà ce qu'il est vous
avez compris balme en plus les tracteurs
donc c'est quasiment impossible de
sortir quoi c'est une petite dictature
est alors pour moi c'était absolument
génial comme toi je peux même pas ce que
c'était un voyage dans le temps un
siècle en arrière mais ça marche dans
l'autre sens aussi
c'est à dire que pour eux on est des
extraterrestres croire et ça ça se
remarque surtout dans le regard des
enfants des enfants qui découvrent pour
la première fois une caméra qui voit des
gens habillés différemment quand on une
langue qu'ils ne connaissent pas et les
enfants mennonite n'ont pas le sourire
parce que le le jouet sont interdits
chez les mennonites l'amusement en fait
c'est un péché donc il faut faut pas
s'amuser là bas sauf chez jacob jacques
hop c'est un mennonite que j'ai croisé
un peu par hasard à l'extérieur de la
colonisation une colonie donc ça se fait
plusieurs dizaines d'hectares il ya des
enclos il ya une sortie à l'extérieur de
la colonie il ya une buvette avec tenus
par des boliviens et à une petite
supérette quoi et là j'en étais en train
de boire un verre avec mes collègues et
on tombe sur sur jacques pin ce genre
mennonite qui achète une bouteille de
whisky en loucedé quand il ya évidemment
c'est interdit l'alcool la main mais ça
donne envie aux moi je me dis il faut
absolument je le rencontre qu'on en
sache un peu plus et jacob le lendemain
il a failli nous invite chez lui et on y
va le lendemain on arrivait à 11h jacob
venait de se lever une grosse gueule de
bois et chez jacob il y avait des jouets
en fait jacob c'était le rebelle du
village quoi et ses enfants étaient
hyper cool vous voilà il avait petit
trottinette et tous ne st pas jacob il
avait même un appareil photo cachée sous
son lit mais les albums de souvenirs
chez jacob sont pas comme chez nous ce
qui me les a montrés est donc très vite
je tombe sur sa collection de photos d'
accident de calèche accident de la route
de mai
défiguré ou même de petits mennonite qui
naissent malformés parce que vu que ils
vivent en vase clos bas il n'y a pas de
mélanges et ils se marient très souvent
entre cousins message and type man c'est
pas super et déjà comme on sentait bien
quand même que qui voulait qu'ils
voulaient partir de la communauté mais
mais en fait ils pouvaient pas ils
étaient coincés quoi parce qu'il était
né là il parle il fallait parler un
petit peu espagnol mais pas suffisamment
pour pouvoir sans partir est d'ailleurs
en bolivie qui a même des programmes de
réinsertion pour ces mennonite qui sont
soit chassé ou soit qu'ils décident de
fuir leur communauté je suis allé aussi
dans des communautés où les gens à
priori avait choisi de s'extraire du
monde mais pour autant j'ai remarqué à
chaque fois un point commun c'est le
besoin de faire échapper son esprit où
c'est penser à un moment ou un autre et
et jacob
vous l'avez vu à lui c'était l'alcool
s'est livré sans ce qui lui permettait
de 200 furent un peu mais je suis
également allé dans une communauté enfin
sur le la péninsule du mont athos ou là
sont reclus près d'un millier de moines
orthodoxes et eux en fait leur moyen de
s'échapper ils sont vraiment trop
hissant chopin c'est la prière en fait
ils ont ils pris cinq fois par jour et
c'est le moment où ils peuvent
s'échapper de ce quotidien très austère
je suis allé également chez les rastas
en jamaïque mais les vrais rasta c'est à
dire ceux qui vivent en dehors du
système dans l'est dans les montagnes
au-dessus de kingston et bien eu quand
ça vous le savez mais il les rastas de
refus mais les gens sauf qu'ils ont une
bonne excuse parce que c'est pour se
connecter à jo leur dieu le tout
puissant pour finir je suis allé aussi
en dans une commune aux ex allié dans
une communauté qui s'appelle slab city
aux états unis c'est dans le désert
californien
et là c'est les perdus de l'amérique en
fait c'est mad max en plein désert et
eux c'est tout ça réuni c'est l'alcool
c'est les joints c'est la prière
puisqu'il ya une messe tous les
dimanches mais c'est aussi à l'aise dès
méthamphétamine il ya quand même un
point commun que plus positif que j'ai
remarqué c'est que la plupart ces
communautés elles sont ultra connecté
avec la nature elles sont super écolo
vue qui vivent en autarcie
il doit vivre en autosuffisance donc en
fait ils mangent que ceux qui cultivent
à côté de chez eux
donc ça c'est super parce qu'il ya zéro
émission de gaz à effet de serre et puis
également ils n'ont pas de produits de
pesticides donc tout est bio et la
plupart sont végétariens alors les
moines du mont athos malien un moine qui
m'avait expliqué pourquoi il était
végétarien il m'a dit que parce que si
quand il manger de la viande était trop
vigoureux mais il s'est créé tétreault
de sperme et donc ils préfèrent éviter
quoi donc en tout pour cette série gp2
séries là j'ai fait une vingtaine de
pays et dans ma carrière j'ai dû faire
une cinquantaine de destinations
mais je vais vous faire une confidence
je n'aime pas voyager
je n'aime pas voyager parce que je pense
avoir de l'empathie pour les gens que je
rencontre j'aime pas voyagé dans les
endroits dans les pays où ça va mal où
les gens souffrent et l'empathie en fait
quand on y pense c'est une connexion et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui vous permet
d'avoir une connexion sincère avec les
gens quand la plus sincère possible avec
les gens que vous rencontrez
je pense surtout que l'empathie ça doit
être la première qualité pour un
journaliste merci
[Applaudissements]